foreign
[Music]
it sort of caught us a little
flat-footed Customs and Border Patrol
was actually doing Street releases so
the city of El Paso the ngos the local
shelters said we're at capacity and then
so they they went ahead and released on
the street that's why we saw those
people on the street this week they're
not doing Street releases they haven't
had to that's their last resort from
what they tell us so what they are doing
a lot more this week is decompression
flights and buses
instead of releasing them in this
community they're taking them to other
centers to be processes along the border
from from California down to down
through Texas they're just processing
them at other locations instead of
processing them all right here because
once they're processed they have to
release them
our average now is 1700 apprehensions a
day
every day it's not that the number has
declined it's we've gotten better at
processing city was doing about 200 they
were taking 200 a day now they're taking
400. we used to have two flights that
went out to detention that we have five
flights so when people tell me is this
you know are the numbers dropping
they're really not they're increasing
we're just able to do it a little bit
better than before we did our first
processing center on our own on
September 3rd it was a holiday weekend
we had a senior center on the east side
of town that was closed for the day so
that was our first daily run the
following Tuesday we actually opened
this facility we're at a daily capacity
of about 400. we're there some of these
people don't know how to look at never
used a website so over there we have
staff that will help us schedule these
lights and then over there that station
over there they will take it to the
airport or to the bus station so they
can reach their destination and get over
there and that's where we wait for the
buses from Chicago and New York and uh
once they're getting ready to go out
you'll see the buses outside we'll line
them up we'll move them up and they'll
board their buses to their destinations
whoever doesn't make it to above because
uh at the end of the day maybe we didn't
have a group large enough to accommodate
a full bus they will be taken to a
shelter or to a hotel they'll come back
tomorrow and we'll put them in the next
spot so they can reach their
destinations
there's there's a map on the board we're
trying to connect them with ngos of the
house that a system which travels as
well you know there is certain people
that want to go to a certain
destinations we're also getting them on
Transportation there so even though
there's a charter going somewhere
they're free to get off at the location
where they want to I mean they're free
to leave from right here we do have a
lot of people who choose them they'll
actually walk across the street grab an
Uber grab a taxi and they'll head on
their own that that's fine at this point
in time they've already been processed
by Customs and Border Patrol so we can't
keep them here when we look at
Transportation Charters they're set up
because we have large groups of people
choosing those destinations so that's
why we chartered those locations I think
the difference between what we do and
and you know some of the other Governors
are doing and it is that that we know
that we have someone at the other end
that we're coordinating we're not just
putting them on a bus and then getting
the other you know Community to figure
it out we're not willing to politicize
it in any particular way that's why we
don't accept a lot of things like the
buses and everything from from the
governor because then it becomes a
political issue instead of a a crisis a
humanitarian crisis a migrant crisis and
that's it which how do you how do you
take care of that
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
we'll continue to make sure people are
not released into the street that's our
priority we'll continue to make sure
that people have shelter people have a
warm bed and warm food and clothing
we're trying to do the best we can we
seek reimbursement for the FEMA's
federal emergency food and shelter grant
and so as long as we can get the
reimbursements we can continue doing
this operation it's not our normal
this isn't but but it's what's needed to
be done for the community the community
and those passing through it El Paso is
limited we got we got heart
there's a lot of the people they want to
help but there's only so much
transportation out of El Paso and so
it's about bringing those charters in
it's about looking at alternative areas
to actually release we only have so many
flights and so many buses that leave
town on a daily basis and so once you
fill those up then you start looking at
having to house a lot more people and
that turns into a much larger operation
the reality of it they're not choosing
to stay here we're just a path for them
to get to where they're going their
destination was the United States El
Paso was just the doorway they came
foreign